if you want to know more about the
mystery behind this new character
madison and if you want to know how
you're going to get five dollars in your
account for free
then stick around to the end of this
video this video is sponsored by
privacy.com
personalized cards for each set limits
monthly are one-time use to make sure
that you're safe
say that you're hacked you'll get
notified about the hack
[Music]
zombieland doubletap begins exactly
where the original zombieland began
washington dc
were introduced to what has changed in
zombieland over the last 10 years there
are now different evolutions of zombies
known as the homer
the hawking the ninja and later the
t-800 the characters are living in the
white house where there's a giant mural
of obama he would have been in office at
the time that the zombie apocalypse
started
meaning he had this mural of himself
seems like a callback to bill murray
having artwork of himself in the first
one
hey google what's obama's last name
barack obama's full name is barack
hussein obama ii
the second there are some other
references to the original zombieland
nested in the white house sequence like
when tallahassee is teaching little rock
to shoot a basketball in the basketball
arcade machine
in the first one there's a moment of him
teaching her how to shoot a gun
aren't you uh exhale slowly
squeeze the trigger
when wichita expresses her concerns
about little rock possibly leaving
columbus brushes her hair behind her ear
something that he had long fantasized
about in the first one i had always
my whole life wanted to brush a girl's
hair over her ear tallahassee also has a
twinkie ornament on the front of his car
a reminder about his constant search for
twinkies over the course of the original
there's also a decorative twinkie mascot
stowed in the garage
and he continues the tradition of giving
all of his cars the number three
by the way in the previous video i
pointed out how three was the number of
his favorite race car driver dale
earnhardt and some of you commented that
it was also the age at which he lost his
son
could be a double meaning manner he also
has a pair of threes on his belt buckle
in this new movie double tap takes place
10 years later so
all existing twinkies are expired now
believe it or not twinkies have an
expiration date but he does have a new
target item after the girls make off
with and destroy his vehicle the beast
his new goal is to get another car that
he likes and like the twinkie hunt of
the first movie he endures a string of
disappointments before getting his
reward in the end
after his girlfriend leaves him columbus
meets madison madison
i doubt it was intentional that she's
the living epitome of the stereotypical
blonde jokes that were popular in 2009
but you can choose to see it that way if
you want
it's also unclear if her name is madison
or if she's from madison wisconsin but
i'm guessing she wasn't smart enough to
get the whole clue about the code names
so her name might just be madison
they get back to the white house and
drink mountain dew code red out of the
presidential cups
not the hockey ones actual presidential
cups code red is the beverage that
columbus is addicted to in his virgin
days as a world of warcraft nerd
pre-zombieland
and i already discussed how it
represents a state of emergency in my
episode on the first movie
zombie kill of the week from the first
movie also makes a return this time in
the form of zombie kill of the year
one of the candidates for zombie kill of
the year is this guy knocking over the
leaning tower of pisa to kill some
zombies
i kind of wonder if this is a small
connection to this line from the first
movie
friday night third straight week indoors
world of warcraft leaning tower of pizza
boxes
after wichita returns to the white house
explaining that her sister ran off with
some guy
the four of them set out to find little
rock at elvis home graceland but soon
after find it destroyed and end up at
the hound dog hotel where they spot
tallahassee's old car and wichita makes
a strange mistake that you may not have
noticed the first time through
when i purchase stuff online i'm always
worried about who i'm actually giving my
credit card information out to i mean
how can these people anonymously
collecting your info online really be
trusted that's why i think
everyone should have an account on
privacy.com here's how it works you sign
up for a free account
actually they give you five bucks just
to make your account if you use my link
in the description then you can set up
burner cards and merchant cards so for
example i paid 19.95 per month for my
movie theater subscription
so i'll just make a virtual card with a
19.95 per month spending limit and i
know that they're never going to
overcharge me or double tap my bank
account
there's so many ways that you can use
this to your advantage you know how
there's all these deals online where you
can supposedly get a free trial of
something but they still collect your
payment info so they can charge you the
second that the trial ends
well with privacy.com you can just give
them a burner card with no money on it
so you can safely and confidently use
any free trial
actually for free and by the way it's a
100 free service to use so there's
literally no reason not to have it just
go to the link in the description that's
privacy.com's world to sign up and get
five dollars for free
why would you not do this privacy.com
they all split off into different
sections of the hotel to look for little
rock when wichita is alone she calls out
the name
little rock rather than using her
sister's actual name so do these two
just call each other by their code names
even in private now
or maybe it was just a case of old
habits die hard because she's been using
the code name for 10 years now when
around
columbus and tallahassee meanwhile
little rock isn't even there her and her
new boyfriend berkeley are on their way
to the pacifist community
babylon berkeley comments that babylon
must stand for that cool david gray song
personally i was going to go with the
stars on broadway song but i guess
david gray works fine one other detail
that i loved was when they show up to
babylon and turn in their guns and
there's that one hippie who's holding it
as if it's contaminated or something the
community seems to be reinforced by a
stack of railroad storage containers on
all sides and a van with sliding doors
that serves as the entrance and exit
as they come through i noticed that the
words roller coaster are graffitied on
the van
in the first one the theme park pacific
playland is supposedly the safe haven
and then in this one babylon is
supposedly a safe haven until the end of
both movies when they aren't
you'll be the first to die but i like
your enthusiasm back at the hotel
tallahassee and columbus meet their
doppelgangers i wish they would have
gotten michael sarah to play the jesse
eisenberg double since they were both
very typecast in the era that the
original zombieland came out as the shy
virgin type when those two characters
turn into zombies a big battle ensues at
the hound dog hotel which involves a
couple more throwbacks to that original
movie like tallahassee hitting flagstaff
with a pool cue
a reference to this part and tallahassee
smashing albuquerque with an elvis
guitar with direction from columbus on
when it's safe to swing
don't swing
back on the road again columbus reveals
to wichita that they've actually been
listening to a cd the whole time
record by the band portis head or
possibly porter shed
they aren't quite clear in the
pronunciation porter's head
porter's head poured his head the robots
actually seem to agree on this one this
band was likely chosen because like most
of the characters in zombieland portion
is named after the town of cordesette
not far away from where the band was
formed when tallahassee heads off on his
own he says
i'm not much for goodbyes so and
columbus interrupts him and says please
don't say the pig thing i guess it stuck
with him all
these years
i'm not graded farewell so uh
that'll do pig that's the worst goodbye
i've ever heard
and you stole it from a movie when
nevada saves them in the monster truck
tallahassee brings back another one of
his old lines
thank god for rednecks they end up
making it to the skyscraper with the
t-800s giving chase and tallahassee
herds them off the building hanging from
that hook where a couple of the zombies
are able to latch on to him he yells
back at his friends telling them to
throw something and i seriously thought
for one moment that columbus was just
gonna throw madison
to knock the zombie off of him but uh
lucky for her i guess little rock still
had her gun they're able to barely reel
tallahassee back in by the curved tip of
his boot
perhaps a sign that it was actually a
blessing that he couldn't fit into elvis
presley's actual shoes back at the hound
dog hotel
at the end tallahassee once again gets
what he was looking for this time it's
the cadillac
and i know i'm not supposed to give my
opinion but i just feel the need to say
i walked out of the theater having
mostly enjoyed zombieland doubletap but
the more i think about it the more i
realized that they are all
i mean sure this time they were able to
get away but the zombies are evolving
way faster than humans who are really
just going to continue to run out of
resources as the years go by
in fact it probably won't be long before
the odds catch up with them
unless tallahassee's idea of going to an
island actually works
i've got one more thing you probably
missed i noticed most everyone cleared
out of the theater after the bill mary
garfield 3 interview
so do you have any regrets
garfield maybe and those of you who left
would have missed out on the scene that
plays at the very end of the credits
where they cut back to that interview
and bill demonstrates more hairball
cough ups this time in various languages
so that covers zombieland doubletap but
before you go remember to head to
privacy.com's world and sign up for an
account
as a special treat for cc's world
viewers you're gonna get five dollars to
spend on your first privacy.com purchase
for a limited time only
yeah free money you can put that towards
whatever streaming service you like
go to privacy.comworld and sign up now
and i guess i'll see you all in 10 years
when we check back in on these
characters again or if you can't wait
that long you should subscribe to cz's
worlds for new horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
you